holds his line about like we're you like
good [ __ ] or something like he like
Basie is like there's like either you
[ __ ] indoors and you're a man and you're
okay with it or it goes thing goes on
the other side if you don't care about
it when you ain't no man at all
because real men don't care where other
men turn that's just a fact the other
side of it is we do care join my dude
Red Dead Redemption 2 is out everyone's
been playing in we all got a lot of
stories so I thought it'd be cool to
round up our favorite one so far
what do you have what do I have
well I think the most memorable one for
me had to have been when I was coming
down the mountain at night both in game
and in real life it was like 2 a.m.
because playing late at night I was
traveling down the mine I was going
through like a bunch of different cabins
like some abandoned some with people in
it I came across this one goth my horses
stationed near a lake I like right at
the foot of a couple of cliffs the
moment I walk into it I see this green
glow coming from the ceiling
so basically what happens is that this
is green glow and there is a freaking
UFO just hovering above the cabin and
like once I step foot and I heard that I
saw the gloves look just like what is
going on like are there a Lisak because
I had no idea
yeah it wasn't only until after that I
read the letter that was on the desk in
the cabin that mentioned this cult of
people basically being waiting for
aliens to take them to like a promised
realm
[Music]
and I was just freaking out so hard just
trying to figure out what did I just
stumble onto you lucked out on the exact
timing there and it's so great that like
there are those moments in the game
where you know even though you there are
plenty of guides to find like Easter
eggs and hidden stuff when you can come
across that kind of stuff on your own
like organically yeah it's like nothing
else I've ever found and what about you
for me
it it's like a two-parter and it has to
go down to the raccoon man here so
everyone has their first bar fight with
I thinking his name's Tommy that big guy
right some time later I go back into the
bar just like you know soak in just the
atmospheres this guy is just talking to
himself or he's kind of talking to the
bartender but he doesn't give a [ __ ]
whoever will was a little listen to him
he's hammered he's basically the the
drunk from Team America who has that
line like there are three types of
people people dicks [ __ ] an [ __ ]
and he's rambling he is talking about
how back in the day people used to [ __ ]
indoors and how you're oh that makes you
a man for doing so we didn't care you
know why because real men don't care
where other men turn I am I guess a
little too close to him because he
because he looks at me and just one look
he just decked me across the face state
face what continues then is a two-minute
fight that lasts till sundown it's night
time it's still going on I'm like on the
verge of dying there's this moment where
I like grab for the deck and it's just
my trip to punch he's just like this
tank he will not go down finally does
and then of course I like take his
record after on and walk out the whole
bar is watching by the way just like
awkward it's as comical the thing is is
like that in itself was probably my
favorite moment but the best was that
Jake and I on a stream were playing yes
and this is like eight hours of gameplay
later that I go back to this bar and
sure enough he's in the bar and this is
in Valentine the thing is for standing
there and we're noticing it's like holy
[ __ ] his hat isn't on his head meaning I
still have his hat it was this buildup
of like oh my god let's see what happens
if I go back to him with the hat on so I
run outside with sheer excitement that I
accidentally like go to someone else's
horse and they pull a gun on me I'm
excited run horse I get the Hat I put it
back on the second I opened the doors
the bar he stands up and just beelines
it towards me and we get in like a whole
nother fight they had one thought about
that like going back later and wearing
his hat because his hat and he totally
knew and people will remember you from
like previous encounters basically it
was just so awesome to like there was
that build-up just to like oh man I hope
he notices will this go will this work
and if it didn't it would have been a
bummer but the fact that it did was made
it truly amazing
god I some I've thrown through the
window yeah what's up my hat so I've got
one more story I think and this is not
nearly as fun this has to do with
basically like a side quests in roads in
which go to the gunsmith and if you go
around the side of the building you'll
notice that there's a guy kind of like
in bars almost like it is prison so he's
being held at the bottom of the gunsmith
cellar dam and he's like you know help
me how I need to get out of here crazy
guys got me locked up and so you go up
to the gunsmith and then you basically
rob him and tell him like open up her
cell let me see what's down there and so
I do that and I'm I'm pulling the gun to
his head like the entire time he leads
me down to where a guy's being held in
what looks like a ghost like a kid's
room but this is like a fool like a
grown man basically and the prisoner is
like help me out this guy's got me
trapped in here because he thinks I'm
his sons and so what transpires is that
the guy the gunsmith starts talking
about how like this really sad story
about how he lost his kids like this
terrible accident please forgive me I
know it was wrong
I just couldn't face that he was gone
prisoner the other guy he looks so much
like him he kidnapped him kept him down
there and like I think who knows what
happens between that time and then when
you found him
but eventually prisoners like Bill and
the husband is just sobbing on the floor
just like nothing else matters to me
anymore like I lost my son lost the guy
that almost looked like him and it's
just like you're just sitting there
wondering like okay do I just leave him
there do I kill him please forgive me
it's too late for apologies
you just count yourself lucky that I
don't kill you for what you did I don't
know what else you want from me yes I
just wanted to find out like how
terrible this can get yeah and so I kill
them shoot them and then what happens
next is that I realized that I can go
upstairs and loot every single box of
ammo from the store and I decided to do
that and while I'm doing that the
saddest music starts playing in the
background
you're just so somber and like it's what
the game is doing is reminding you how
terrible you are because it's not just
one box of bullets and then you leave
yours like 50 and I just keep bringing
them into my bag over and over and it's
like oh my god yeah and also the fact
that I know that I'm gonna get away with
us nobody saw them nobody heard it right
I'm just gonna walk out as if nothing
happened the game does a really great
job at like just making your decisions
matter but like in a way that shows you
not like the it doesn't show you the
consequence in like oh you pick a bad
decision and then you know later on like
you have a different dialogue path it's
just like that immediate point right
after that terrible decision yeah is
like the most and I think that's where
it shines words like it makes you feel
like actually feel like a terrible
person
yeah totally it does a really great job
maybe you feel like sad
[Music]